[Applaudissements]
on peut s'habiller de noir ou de blanc
l'un et l'autre sont
élégants on peut boire du champagne ou
du mousseux quand on veut être un peu
joyeux on peut jouer au dé ou au poquet
quand on veut perdre son salaire mais
pour connaître un véritable amour que
l'on gardera pour
toujours un cœur n'importe quel cur pour
faire une vie pas n'importe quelle vie
il faut savoir dire non même quand on
veut dire oui pour faire une vie pas
n'importe quelle vie il faut mon cœur
pas n'importe quel cœur il faut un cœur
pas n'importe quel cœur faire une vie
pas n'importe quelle vie et je peux te
jurer qu'il te faut me dire oui pour
faire ta vie pas n'importe quelle vie il
faut un cur pas n'importe quel
cœur peux porter un manteau jaune ou
gris tu es toujours aussi jolie mettre
en couronne ou en long tes cheveux tu es
toujours les mêmes
yeux te coucher dans un lit ou dans le
foin et faire l'amour tout aussi bien
mais si tu veux connaître un vrai
bonheur petite fille prend mon
cœur il faut un cœur pas n'importe quel
cœur pour faire une vie pas n'importe
quel VI et je peux te jurer qu'il te
faut me dire oui pour faire ta vie pas
n'importe quelle vie il faut mon cœur
pas n'importe quel cœur il faut un cœur
pas n'importe quel cœur faire une vie
pas n'importe quelle vie et je peux te
jurer qu'il te faut me dire oui pour
faire ta vie pas n'importe quelle vie il
faut mon cœur pas n'importe quel
cœur
il faut savoir dire non même quand on
veut dire oui pour faire une vie pas
n'importe quelle vie il faut un cœur pas
n'importe quel
[Musique]
cœur